live Oscars golden anniversary the 50th
annual academy award presentation
you
we're in the plaza the Dorothy Chandler
Pavilion of the Music Center in Los
Angeles California for Oscar golden
anniversary these crowds have been
gathered since early morning watch
screams most glamorous figure for
tonight's milestone event both
today
a16 wait 8 pounds 8 ounces pipe
13 and 1/2 inches named Oscar
Oscar was born fifty years ago in
Hollywood California the proud parent
was the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences the founders never dreamed
that its spec would reach beyond
California but over half a century we've
watched it grow into a symbol of
excellence not only here but
internationally and we've all grown
right along with Oscar
that cute you
who would try to get by while we laughed
at his take look how far just look how
far we
look how much just how much look how
much we've grown since that time that
sublime Valentino the Sheikh said
romance with his aunts long before films
could speak look how much
how much we
you
we've been through pranksters and
monsters and gangsters and look how far
just how far we've come through that I
treat rather stare light as air west
wings on a speech
look how we progress
even when rain fell we'd never complain
hell salmon death star
you
real guests here from space or the
maximun pack and the pie in the face
young Jonah
in such a short amount of time is really
very simple
the reason is people people who are
dedicated to excellence
and it's the 50th anniversary of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences we cherish our past Oscar
winners who honor us and whom you Terry
Oh
Oh
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. Howard W Cox
from all of you
welcome to Hoskins 50th anniversary
party you know I've been a movie since I
was a little kid but being on the stage
with these Oscar winners I'm really
shook up in any way I'm gonna do
something I haven't done before I'm
gonna introduce two wonderful people
past presidents of the Academy between
them had 50 nominations and three Oscars
gentlemen was the winner fit to kill a
mockingbirds the lady a two-time winner
for dangerous and Jezebel Betty where
are you Betty Davis and Gregory
fifty years ago the academy awards were
presented without fanfare at the dinner
in los angeles a sort of family bash it
was for film artists and technicians
it's still essentially that but the
annual event has so captured the public
imagination that it is now front-page
news
our award ceremony is seen on television
in 50 countries by 300 million people
we've come a long way buddy this one big
night a year provides the academy with
revenue which supports its library the
world's most extensive on the subject of
film its scholarships and intern
programs for young filmmakers its
student Film Awards its lectures
seminars retrospective and its national
information service all designed to
serve the cause of excellence in
filmmaking and film scholarship the
voting procedures work like this all
active academy members may vote on
nominations for the five pictures of the
year other nominations are made by
members of each academy branch for
example writers nominate the five
outstanding writing achievements of the
year actors nominate actors directors
nominate directors etc later
all members vote on those nominations to
select the final Awards the secret
ballots are sent to the Academy's bonded
accountants Pricewaterhouse and company
for tabulation foreign language
documentary and short films are the only
exceptions only members who attend
comprehensive special screenings may
vote for them results are known only to
Price Waterhouse and company until the
sealed envelopes are opened here tonight
and now mr. president back to you
many years a tradition was to introduce
the representatives of our company that
Odets Pricewaterhouse and tonight let's
go back for old time to do it again
gentlemen the envelopes please Frank
Johnson and John Blair
only they know the secret uh now
nominees you're getting a little nervous
cuz I am we're gonna do something we've
never done we're gonna show you the
director Marty Posada our directors in
the truck you're ready Marty I know
Nelson Riddle are musical directors
ready
so as our master of ceremonies he should
be this is a twenty second time at bat
and he's still batting a thousand on a
very own Bob Hope
thank you very much you're too kind
maybe not too kind but you're wonderful
can you believe this group all in the
same stage at the same time
looks like the road company of the
Hollywood Wax Museum
now they're wonderful they all have
their Oscars but are they happy I feel
funny walking down with all those Oscars
when I'm the only one that had to show
my American Express card to get on stage
but you know we all hear people refer to
the magic of Hollywood and as far as I'm
concerned that group you saw behind me
is the magic of Hollywood
some of these people have one two and
three Oscars each their names have been
taken and they'll be getting their
obscene phone calls in due time for as
many Oscar winners are absent Liz
Taylor's back in her farm in Virginia
still trying the milk of chicken anyway
I just want to say good evening and
welcome to the real Star Wars this is
the 50th
this is the 50th academy award show and
the Oscars were first given out I hadn't
even act started acting in films yet and
throughout its 50-year history the
Academy has maintained that attitude my
agent told me don't worry about not
winning this time remember you're still
young it's a good thing about having a
90 year old agent well tonight you'll
see the real Hollywood The Hollywood
with a heart as the winners mount the
podium you'll see their fellow actors
applauding cheering and yelling in the
true tradition of the theater break a
lake this is exciting
theaters filled with brilliant attracted
gifted people all asking themselves the
same question how can I get on camera so
I can deduct this outfit I'm wearing
what am i the furs the jewels the
glamour looks like the opening the
Beverly Hills Taco Bell I haven't seen
so much expensive jewelry go by since I
watched Sammy Davis jr. house sliding
down Coldwater Canyon
coming in coming into the theater
tonight did you notice the ostentatious
display of national chauvinism all the
English stars arrived in Rolls Royces
the Germans and Mercedes limousines the
Italians and Ferraris and the Americans
and Toyotas and how about all those
black limousines in the parking lot
looked like the Godfather's Tupperware
party what crowds outside I have the
first time when I arrived here tonight
my car was surrounded by packs of
screaming women clawing to get at me you
don't believe me just asked my driver
John Travolta pictures of sure changed
since the first Oscars were handed out
if wings were made today Buddy Rogers
and dick island would be walking into
the sunset holding hands Hollywood was a
little different when Oscar was born the
Sunset Strip was a girl named Wanda
Latour goodbye girl was a silent movie
actress who couldn't talk and fifty
years ago the boy got the girl today
it's anybody her mother father brother a
cocker spaniel and we've gone through
all kinds of fads since then the Giant
musical that have two or three hundred
dancers on stage and maybe five or six
carpenters to work on Anne Miller's hair
and there's quite a difference between
Fred Astaire and Ginger Rogers dancing
the Continental and Marlon Brando doing
the tango tonight's awards have received
a lot of publicity one article said that
this year the women had the best parts
I'm so old-fashioned I thought women
have always had the best parts but let's
and break
but some great pictures were nominated
the turning point reminded me I once had
thoughts about going into the ballet
then I saw the tights the guys wore and
I knew I could never pass the physical
1977 be known as the year Star Wars
which has grossed over 200 million
dollars that's even more that some
baseball players make I think the
biggest surprise of the year is young
John Travolta in Saturday Night Fever
and I mean young I have wine older than
he is Saturday night movie that's the
movie that John put on a great white
suit and then tried to wear it out from
the inside and Julie I loved I like a
good cry but that's pretty obvious why
else would I be here Marsha Mason and
Richard Dreyfuss were terrific in the
goodbye girl Richard plays the role of a
tender-hearted man who consents to share
his apartment with Marsha and her
daughter played by ten-year-old Quinn
Cummings who was what I imagined William
Buckley was at 10
anyway Quinn plays a little girl with
the vocabulary somewhere between gore
Vidal and red fox and Oh God is up for
Best Screenplay it's just a shame George
Burns believes his part in that picture
he wants if he wants why now he orders
it from Sparkletts
we're in a hurry he really does believe
he really does believe he has miraculous
powers since that film he must be
starting to date again but I do really
hope that Oh God wins something Los
Angeles can't stand 40 more days of rain
Close Encounters of the Third Kind got
eight nominations we believe they were
all from this world and for years I've
been telling my family comedians are
never nominated for anything how do you
like that Woody Allen ruining my home
life for me
Woody Allen was nominated for Best were
actor writer and director and he was
indicted for restraint of trade three
nominations what therapy but if he wins
it will make history it'll be the first
time an Oscar carried the winner home